from yeah he's gotta yeah yeah okay why
do you want no what stranger things you
weirdo
well I auditions for the ein I've said
this before why we can't watch anything
Bobby we've now painted ourselves into a
corner I know I have sat in the rain
they the alive twice oh yeah what's the
character
which character before the teacher
teacher in the first he's also the
second season of a [ __ ] he made it to
both seasons yeah yeah and then audition
the second year second season
mmm cuz he like the first and I just
didn't I was so bring it cuz in the
first warrior own worst I was called on
something else and it was just a night
it was taught Montauk and I just went in
and I just kind of went I don't this is
I was [ __ ] rated Yeah right when you
don't but now it's a cultural thing
imagine now you're sitting yeah and with
that in it nah I can't do it I know you
know what I usually do by the way and
you can have this I usually walk in and
I just look right at everybody and I'm
like I'm gonna pass based on the
material it's great and then everybody
just goes yeah what if I said that
before you that would suck I read before
do based on the material so any room
gets a laugh and you go in there and
Bobby does this and he really destroys
it you know that's that's a classic
Bobby joke
yeah yeah Bobby's been doing that for
years how do you yeah that's the other
big bummer is when you walk into the
waiting room and you see all your
doppelgangers we've got some right oh my
god I got your and I've got some that
are just I love their work yeah that
that look you when you go into room who
do you see who do I hate to see no who
do you generally see I'll see your Andy
Daly's
Andy Daly oh sorry yeah Uncle Jim yeah
yeah I'll see your rub yubel's I'll see
your oh I'll see your John Michael
Higgins Allah yeah
yeah he and I both have that kind of
like bon vivant like angry authoritarian
who might also like be into dog grooming
and yeah you know like yeah yeah a bit a
bit of a dandy you know yeah I see the
you know I I see some time Steven Yeun
twice sure right you know he I'm 30
years older than him and it's like
people white people can't tell you just
can't yeah I mean I love when he walks
into a room literally turning gosh I
leave boy all the way I want to get this
but he's just heartbreaking drama guy
but he isn't he yeah but he's from
second city you train yeah yeah and he's
very funny gotta get rid of him no he's
a wonderful guy and a kind of a
dreamboat do you know him
no I know him a little bit I know him
alone we met like twice and he was great
just one of the nicest yeah it was great
but now a lot of those guys you know
have of they're ahead of me now know so
like the Randall Parks and the DA John
chose although they're my class of
people I don't see them mmm because
they're the they're the leads and I'm
still getting like you know the Chinese
waiver or you know Sarah yeah really
yeah or they for Europe yeah for your
obtained yeah that might be yeah I was
actually okay so I was at walking around
the Paramount lot I had to do something
there so I took my son I just had to
kill some time out at Paramount we
walked around the whole lot and they
were filming on the back lot and I was
like oh and there's like a nice P as a
come off you can watch and I'm like oh
cool I'm like what is this and she's
like it's a Lucky Strike commercial I'm
like what she's like the cigarettes yeah
I was like oh this is just not for
America she's like no so that like
there's stuff that exists yeah world is
very small when you go to like when you
go to like Japan you'll see you know
DiCaprio with a watch yeah you know man
you know Rolex you'll see Brad Pitt
selling oil but some
this is a chevron or whatever it was an
old Woody Allen like whiskey ad and
stuff but it's all overseas yeah why is
that you do do big a-list actors ago I
don't want to be seen in a certain way
in America some of the guys with the
watch they don't even put it on it's
just like near them right there like for
me in the Philippines everything all the
beers and all the rooms were Steven
Seagal his line was I found gold in the
Philippines and Steven Seagal is the
biggest thing growing up that's Duchess
all you saw was Steven Seagal you mean
Steven Seagal special Russian envoy to
the United States three special Russian
envoy what is it Oh before we continue
we have
[Music]